so this doesn't quite fit in terms of
hyperbolic polynomials although real
rootedness is very much something that
we interested in for the Riemann
zeta-function that I'll remind you about
in a second I guess given the audience I
should make clear what I'm talking about
which I will explain in a second ball of
wool of what I described here is joint
with Michael Rubinstein we've been
working on this sort of thing for years
he's perhaps more than anyone in the
world able to compute zeroes of L
functions far further than anyone else
used to be on let's go
Rubinstein has taken over and for many
years we've been trying to understand
the computational complexity of this
question and as you will see we've got
to some point I think all right so let
me frighten you with some slide there
which I'll explain now what I'm talking
about in a very down-to-earth and most
important case and then I'll return to
that and then explicate the entire
discussion for just elliptic curves
because that's got all the beef and it's
got all the interest so the problem we
interested in is we have some kind of
zeta function like the riemann zeta
function
and it's generalizations it's the
product of the primes or a series
representation and as you probably know
this function has an analytic
continuation and functional equation
that coming from the additive structure
and because of this product of primes
which is equivalent to unique
factorization it marries the primes and
this analytic function in a quite deep
way and Riemann I want to explain this
point Riemann showed that if you take pi
to the minus s over to gamma s over 2
times the Riemann zeta function which I
always call lambda of s this will be a
generalization there if you append these
elementary functions a gamma function in
this exponential function then he proved
a very famous functional equation
which relates lambda of 1 minus s 2
lambda bass and simultaneously
analytically continuing this function
it's of the form 1 over s it's got a
pole 1 of s minus 1 plus 1 plus
something which is rapidly convergent in
the in in the plane in any vertical
strip in the plane and so this looks
like so about this I won't write down
his formula this allowed him to
analytically continue get this
functional equation and make this very
famous Riemann hypothesis which he
needed for certain purposes it's not so
well known that riemann himself before
making this conjecture computed a few
zeros and in order to compute zeros here
to overcome a great difficult point
which is going to be the center of this
lecture we sort of discovered all the
key analytic aspects of this and the
point is this that what if if we on the
line so all the zeros of this completed
function they're supposed to be on the
line 1/2 the first zeros he computed
himself roughly at 1/2 plus i times 14
something that's quite high up symmetric
and then he computed the first three
that i'll get back to this in a second
and why is this such a difficult problem
specially if the first 0 so high is that
the formula that you have and all
formulae that you naive formula that you
have for this function have a gamma
function there and the gamma function
decays exponentially like e to the minus
PI over 2 times the absolute value of T
when T gets large this is just the
earliest formula so if you riemann and
all you have is a pencil and paper and
you want to compute that the first zeros
on the line 1/2 you didn't make this
conjecture as I say in a vacuum the way
he would check it in the way it did
check it is you do a contour integral of
Zeta prime over Zeta R and here once you
have an expression once you can compute
theta
accurately to compute the integral 1
over 2 pi the integral of zeta prime del
visited over this contour and you count
how many zeroes there you get a number
and because it's an integer the count if
you are if you get a number which is
close to 1 then is exactly 1 0 and then
by the functional equation that 0 has to
be on the line 1/2 if there's 1 0 in it
and people have gone very high up as i
say the first zeros is so high that e to
the minus PI over 2 times 14 is a tiny
number for a guy working with the
pencils and paper so he had to find a
different way to understand this and he
did it it's in his NA class nobody
noticed this there's not less people
looked at it like Hilbert many other
people couldn't understand what's in the
nathless and tole collared Wiggs Eagle
came along and he understood in these
pages what Riemann was doing that he'd
computed the first few zeroes to about
10 decimal places and I will call this
the Riemann ziggo formula because he go
explained it and it's gonna be the gold
standard for computation and what
Riemann's method shows is by changing
with weights he is able to show that you
can write Zeta at high T so I suppose
I'm interested in the complexity I'm a
1/2 plus I TT is a very big number maybe
10 to the 20 and I'm at high T I could
he can eat discovers you can write the
Riemann zeta function as a series of
lengths roughly square root of the
conductor the conductor here will be t
square root of t terms and that's the
gold standard he he found that you could
compute the zeroes in that speed square
root of hi t so he could get this guy at
14 and if you look at any tables or any
data on that on the web you'll see
nobody can really get much more than ten
to the twenty or twenty to ten to twenty
three because the square root of that is
roughly the number of operations you
have to do to get zeros so let's go for
example computer the 10 to the 20th zero
and it's 70 million neighbors then
compute all the zeros up to 10 to 20 but
any there's some interesting things
all right so that's the Riemann
zeta-function and have we mentioned this
formula which I didn't explain and the
general setting is you have a
generalization of this where there will
be coefficients here and there'll be a
product here with coefficients there and
the cases I'll be interested in come
from algebraic geometry I'll show you in
a second so the local factors will be
coming from looking at some variety mod
P and the big theorem is a big
conjecture which is known in many cases
is certain elf functions which
generalize the Riemann zeta-function
have analytic continuation z' and
functional equations and there's a
number so I'll be interested in
computing the zeroes of such an elf
function not high up but rather low down
mainly at the point central point so the
central point one half turns out always
to be the most interesting in these more
general elf functions which are self
dual and is a very important number this
entire talk is going to be about this
root number which is a plus or minus 1
which says the functional equation goes
from s into 1 minus s and there's a
conductor which is I said square root T
there which is called n of Pi which when
you have object like this and I'm going
to explicate one in a minute certain
panic this conductor is measuring
ramification and this whole problem that
I'm interested in yeah is to try
understand the complexity of
ramification and I'll be assuming
anything I want
specifically the Riemann hypothesis as I
go along or any other conjectures
because the proof of the pudding and I'm
going to show you algorithms as if they
run and they assume some conjectures and
they run and the proof the pudding is
whether they run nothing else ok so
there is to any automatic form whatever
that is a integer which measures
ramification and it measures the
complexity of computing zeros and we
won't be talking about zeros high up
we'll be talking about zeros especially
near the point of 1/2 or at 1/2 all
right so let me explicate this and this
is the only example you need to think
about and even this will quickly be
replaced by a purely polynomial model
problem which there
main problem reduces to alright so you
have an elliptic curve which are put in
via stress form I'm working of the
integers I don't even continue to form
put it in the simplest form that's y
squared equals a cubic and there's some
other terms and their coefficients and
we given this global elliptic curve
define over the integers over the
rationals if you wish and you form the
standard invariants don't look at them
too carefully the most important thing
is the discriminant which is the
discriminant of the cubic now given
elliptic curve like this and I'll make
some assumptions about the coefficients
they mine are the relatively prime
conditions about the c4 at polynomial a
and C's 6 and if this is not true you
can get around that without too much
difficulty and the issue is that when I
take this elliptic curve and I reduce it
mod P and I look at the number of
solutions over the finite field with P
elements which is so the name of the
game in this whole talk is I'm going to
be able to my ideas I'm gonna compute
this elliptic curve mod P for many small
piece he may go up to log of the
conductor or maybe the conductor to the
1/2 and the assumption is I can and I'll
show you that's a theorem that you can
compute the local factors very quickly
and logarithm number of steps so you
compute these numbers and that are
numbers that you can have in your hands
and now you want to be able to say
something about the zeros over the root
number of this elliptic curve by
computing small numbers that might so
that's a complexity question all right
so the two key numbers of the conductor
of this the conductor let me assume the
conduct is square-free that's an issue
but one that's not so serious so this
I've assumed the discriminant in fact is
square three and I'll assume these other
minor things here then the root number
and this is the most important thing for
us here the root number of this elliptic
curve the sign of the functional
equation depends on some Legendre symbol
now a Legendre symbol a B or Jacobi
symbol is something you can compute in
logarithm number of stagger rhythm
the root is numbers the sign of the
functional equation of the L function so
the OL function of the elliptic curve
will be a series and a product and the
root number is the sign of the function
equation global sign of the functional
equation of the L function of this
elliptic curve and that global root
number is gotten by computing over all
primes which divide the conductor it's
come all the come from ramification so
if you want to compute the root number
you're more or less as far as we now
have to factor the conductor it's just a
sign it's just a parity and it's the
most as I will explain the biggest
secret secret kept by by a number the
number of prime factors yeah yes that's
a good question actually I don't know I
it comes back to directly if you have an
directly l function with period Q the
conductor is is what we call it it may
be other reasons that the way extrovert
conductor but it's the most important
thing it's the product of the number the
prices at which this object has bad
reduction
we write probably comes from German yeah
anyway it's the most important number
and this number is also very important
so the Sun and the global conductor now
the root number is essentially this
Legendre symbol this Legendre symbol is
something you can compute quickly so if
I give you a Legendre symbol a B it's a
plus or minus 1 there's a reciprocity of
gas that says a B is BA times something
explicit so you can just repeat
repeatedly hobb the size of the numbers
and that's the logarithm number of steps
just like Euclid's algorithm to get that
so this is not going to be difficult to
compute but this is a beautiful number
and that's the number I'm really
interested in understanding it's
essentially the root numbers especially
as far as computation goes so the root
number and this Mobius function the
Mobius function is the parity of the
number of prime factors of a number say
it's square-free as I'm assuming here
and we don't know how to compute that
quickly without factoring and my belief
is they are the same complexity and
that's the problem I'm trying to
understand can we compute this number
quickly now if you work with the
elliptic curves or any of these L
functions you really eager to understand
the order of vanishing of the l function
of this elliptic curve at the center
because there's a famous conjecture
called the birch when it entire
conjecture which gives you the rank of
the elliptic curve in terms of the order
vanishing so the parity of the order of
vanishing I'm assuming all these
conjectures the parity would be given by
the root number the order of vanishing
is something that we rarely interested
to understand and the number of steps we
need to compute the root number well
that our discoveries discuss in a second
but by Riemann's gold-standard
it takes square root of the conductive
steps to compute all these things and if
you don't use our functions if you think
you're going to get compute the number
of solutions for the dive in T an
equation the rank is the number of
rational points the rank of the group of
rational points it
well the solutions are so big you'll
never see them so there is no other way
to compute things quickly so these
global L functions carry tightly the
information all built into the conductor
all right so just again for this
elliptic curve case there is there local
factors which when I multiply out will
give lambda and either I'll have a
series representation or product
representation for this global L
function of the elliptic curve and
there's a beautiful theorem of scope
using a little bit of algebraic geometry
to compute the number of points so you
give an elliptic curve in the form that
I gave it to you now I say how many
points has got mod P with P's and prime
it may be that P divides the conductor
this bad reduction but the for the for
this lecture you should think of the
conduct as being a massive number 10 to
the 200 and all this prime factors are
bigger than ten to the hundred and I'm
computing these coefficients how many
solutions are there to this elliptic
curve mod P where P is small my bit may
be going up to conductor to a small
power or may be going up the log of the
conductor so the question is can you
compute the number of solutions to that
equation of Rafah not filled quickly and
scoff I think you will use student of
Lenstra
maybe even Berkeley but anyway Renee
scoff is an amazing algorithm which has
been implemented which computes the
number AP which is there's only one
number in the elliptic curve case
there's one number here that you when
you unwrap fi that one number that you
have to put you in a quadratic
polynomial and the Frobenius of the
elliptic curve mod p and that number he
computes in poly log P steps it's log P
to the six-step so you can compute the
coefficients quickly and so the problem
we're trying to understand is if you can
compute the coefficients quickly can you
compute something about the zeroes of
the old function and let me go back to
the riemann story the gold-standard i
call it if for the riemann formula i
said he writes down value of zeta at
high t in terms of two series which
whose lengths are roughly square root of
the conductor in length each and that's
why you can compute the value very
quickly but that was rude those two
series have
depend on knowing the route number so
you do need to know the route number and
that's important because I'm this whole
lectures about trying to determine the
route number with very little data so
you do need to know the route number and
if you do then this Riemann's Eagle
formula allows you to compute anything I
want in square root of the conductor
plus little o1 steps so that's the gold
standard and that's standard we are
eager to beat and I repeat that the
route global route number is a product
of all primes of some local things that
you can compute and so we don't know any
way of computing this without first
factoring the conductor the other thing
that Riemann allows you to compute and
this is going to be what we're going to
be setting our goals that is I'm
assuming Riemann the Riemann hypothesis
that is for this llll function anything
that comes along like this and you could
ask how many zeros are there on the line
a half up to height T asking how many
zeros are they of the L function with
they're all supposed to be on the line a
half between 0 and T and I call that s
ET and of course Riemann's method allows
you to compute that in square root of
the conductor steps okay and that's
accounting an exact count of the number
of zeros of the l function so the gold
standard is square root and the big
question is can you do better can you do
something sub exponential or maybe you
can get something that's polynomial now
I want to explain why this is of such
interest to us is the parity of a number
the möbius is where everything breaks
down in civvy are-- is something called
the parity principle it stops us doing
everything we're trying to do it's very
difficult analytically to tell where
their numbers got an auto an even number
of prime factors it's a lost secret that
the number keeps if you're the
interested in machine learning I was
wondering try teach a machine to guess
what Martin U of n is for large n with
any probability of doing better than
just flipping a coin I don't think
you'll learn anything it's I have
conjectures about the
randomness in Mobius and it's it's a
fundamental thing theoretically it's
also a fundamental thing theory in terms
of factoring so I'm saying I don't have
a proof of this but it looks very cool
looks like it's probably true that
factoring and computing new or in the
same complexity clause
well secretly I believe factoring is
easy anyway so all of these things are
easy but this mankind likes to think you
know your security systems like to
pretend it's hard and in fact this is
one of the reasons I'm very interested
in this is maybe I could do something
that's going better than the best
factoring algorithms to compute the
route number that's our aim you can we
do better than that
so the benchmarks for this problem are
sub-exponential and the next benchmark
would be how sub-exponential compared to
where all factoring algorithms of
bottleneck the number field sieve for
example all right so the theorem that's
what I want to announce here is that we
can compute the root number and we can
compute this counting function for any
elliptic curve in sub exponential time
so but we can't compute how the rank I
can compute the counting function for
some T's not every T I don't know which
T's the t's come in algorithm and they
allow me to compute exactly how many
zeros are there up to some values of T
many values of T but not T's that I can
choose they probe arrived and the root
number can always compute sub
exponentially and I'm already competing
with the best factoring algorithms
without ever factoring the integer so
this is measuring this really is
exploiting this to try understand so
this is what we're trying to do we're
trying to compute this root number it
might have seven prime factors the
möbius conduct is extremely large and
I'm computing that the number of
solutions mod P for very small piece and
I'm telling you up to square root or n
to the epsilon that's what
sub-exponential is and I can tell you
what this sign is without ever factoring
and I'm bottlenecking roughly at the
same place as factory
so was hoping this would completely
smash open factoring but there's going
to be the caveat at the end of the
lecture all right so that's our main
theorem I'll explain it a little bit we
assuming G or H throughout so algorithms
work so that's not an issue and riemann
is true you don't need to worry about
that i'm assuming other conjectures
along the way because i'm going to bring
in bring in random matrix theory in its
strongest form so i'm assuming
conjectures of cats in myself which tell
you about the distributions of zeros of
l functions as you vary in this kind of
range or as you vary over families and
it's connection to random matrix theory
but those conjectures are only used in
convincing nami and and you that the
algorithm terminates quickly the answer
when it feeds out an answer that the
root number is 1 or minus 1 is correct
it's the running time that depends on
these conjectures and incidentally all
the number field serves and all those
nothing is proved there that's all
depend on heuristics and all of that
people just assume or true as they go
along and again the proof of anything is
in the pudding if i can fact that big
number you don't argue they're all some
exponential and the power of in the sub
exponential I haven't quite understood
I'll get to that at the end all right
now we had this idea let me just say
what our basic tool is so it's not
remands method we're going to use
something else that i so called
Riemann's formula it's a formula that
was popularized by andrey vey rarely
written down first by queen anne and
you'll see it's somehow related to
moments in a moment but there's another
way of capturing the relation between
the zeros of these Zeta functions or say
the riemann zeta function and the
coefficients of the primes so if I have
an L function any one of the old
functions I'm talking about and I'm
assuming remands of the zeros or 1/2
plus I
gamma and the gammas are the zeros then
if you take a test function any test
function Schwarz function for which the
Fourier transform is compact support
this is not a self-dual statement for
ATO ality always looks self-dual but
this is not a self-dual statement
because I want to be able to evaluate
feet in the complex Sofie hat is compact
support even then the sum at the gammas
of fee so that's a formula for some
expression involving the zeros is given
explicitly so this called the explicit
formula it's given by the log of the
conductor times fear to zero then a
logarithmic integral involving the
Archimedean factor all of which are easy
to compute here's where the issue is
there's a free hat that log in of a 2pi
so depending on the support of fee and
fee hat you're gonna have some problem
of the supports of the function anyway
fee hats compact support so this if the
supports up to a then login would have a
2pi would go up to a and would restrict
the number of ends in your sum and the
number of ends and the C ends or these
in the IEEE elliptic curve case or the
numbers are now how to compute quickly I
can compute C and n log into a power
steps for each actual coefficients here
are the logarithmic derivative so I want
to explain this because it's going to
come back in my main moment problem that
I'm leading to right now and that is we
take the logarithmic derivative of this
expression we're doing some elementary
complex analysis so we take log
differentiate and then we have a partial
fraction expansion when I take log
Riemann zeta-function has a root number
1 but in general is a W here when I take
log and differentiate I lose that so I'm
gonna try to recover that from this
formula keep that in mind alright so
idea for many years but it took us at
least three years to realize written
there's a conspiracy against us we're
simply to write down a street this is a
system of equations for gamma system of
nonlinear equations for those gammas
wrote down many equations are going to
awesome machines about to solve his
equations and get the zeros and i want
to explain that this wasn't so stupid
because the density of the number of
zeros if you
a pie when he left the curve of
conductor n e the number of zeros
between zero and one will increase will
be basically log of the conductor and
that is exactly why when somehow is
getting into the position where when is
in log of the conductor steps of course
if I want to fact that number it's
number of digits not not so it looks
kind of promising because there are a
few zeros I want to compute maybe the
bottom one and first few zeros and so
you think you put in a test function
localizer there but whenever we try to
do something it all algorithms didn't
work and there was a reason because we
are finally it can't reduce the problem
to something I'm about to show you right
now so the system right down systems of
equation and there is some enemy and now
a couple of enemies that at all
you fighting against the problem reduces
very clearly to this problem so you can
forget everything I said I've got
another half hour and now we're going to
talk about polynomials and this
underdetermined moment problem and I
think it's a stunningly beautiful
problem and we only have a partial
answer to it so in this application the
log of the conductive MA or the morphic
form of my elliptic curves that that's a
number of digits basically will be the
sizes of the matrices that this
discussion is about the problem reduces
entirely to the following problem so
forget everything we have an orthogonal
matrix of size 2n plus 1 by 2 n plus 1
real orthogonal these eigenvalues all on
the circle that's that I look at the
characteristic polynomial it's
palindromic because I'm orthogonal
because I I want to emphasize I don't
tell you whether the determinant is 1 or
minus 1 that determinant is the root
number I'm gonna be trying to guess the
if the determinant is 1 or minus 1 with
some limited amount of data that's what
this problem reduces to completely
so there's a because of the orthogonal
it's a photo matrix and the dimensions
are because if in dimension 2 n plus 1
there is I can value 1 or minus 1
depending on the determinant and then
they could be multiplicities and here
comes the key thing that the system of
equations from the explicit formula
reduced to is that we know the traces of
the powers of a so I'm going I'm given a
I'll be given a at random
the theory will be such that these
conjectures of cats and mind show that
the zeros of L functions behave like
random matrices if they behave like
random numbers we would clean up here so
it turned out that this is why it makes
the secret much harder to find as you
will see is the go anyway right now I'm
just setting up the problem a is an
orthogonal matrix I'll give you a
certain number of traces of powers so
it's just this expression here I don't
know the determinant but I'm giving you
the following SJ zhivets for J equals 1
up to ket 0 up to K and I'm asking you
what can you say about the eigenvalues
exactly and so I'm trying to say can I
recover large information about the
eigenvalue and the problem is a real
algebraic problem real algebraic
geometry problem as you'll see in a
second and it precisely because it's
real algebraic geometry that we have a
chance of saying something interesting
if these if you take an orthogonal
matrix and you don't you know the all
but one coefficient and you get a curve
well then you just don't know where you
are on the curve but the fact that all
the zeros are restricted to be on the
circle means they can't move very far
before they bounce off and you get very
shut tight estimates on the zeros with
an underdetermined problem so so let's
see about when it's determined and when
it's not so if K equals N and you know
the determinant then I have you know n
remember the volume matrix with size 2n
plus 1 so if I know the determinant
that's one of the eigenvalues then i
have another 2 n unknowns but they are
because of a forged on there if theta is
an eigen
so it's minus theta so I just have n
unknowns if K equals n and n equations
so it might sound like that sounds
dangerous but of course this is by the
self reciprocality if you know the
symmetric powers you know all the
symmetric function if you know the
powers you know all the symmetric
function so you know all the
coefficients just double up and then
just you have the characteristic
polynomial and if you worried about
computing the zeros of a characteristic
polynomial my matrix here never has
there I gain values we in a generic
position so we don't have to worry about
high multiplicity it's not an issue here
so you can recover everything and
remarkably that is what it should be
because this corresponds exactly to
Riemann so if we back in the setting
where we have complexity so now in the
rate in the sub exponential algorithm
all be computing things up to n pi
conducted to the alpha well doctor to
the 1/2 is exactly where Riemann can
compute everything and in this reduction
and the reduction from our system is
exact K of a n is 2 alpha so if alpha
equals 1/2 I have K equals N and I'm
just in a position where I can recover
all the coefficients so matches exactly
Riemann's gold standard is just saying
that if you're given all the
coefficients of a polynomial of an or
the characteristic polynomial this
orthogonal matrix you can compute the
zeros but we want to go sub-exponential
so we won't pay over in or this alpha to
be arbitrarily small and that's the
underdetermined problem and it's a real
algebraic geometry problem and what we
basically are given R is this vector Y
in RK of moments and what can we say
about the Thetas so it seems like a
problem that should have been studied I
don't know why it hasn't been studied
there is one part that will connect to
work of Chevy chef Markov and crime it's
connected with moment curves as you'll
see in a second and I'll raise quickly
the main problem right now but what are
we trying to compute so we have an
underdetermined problem so you might say
you forget it you can't compute anything
well it's not true you can compute it
from end
so I'm going to let this is this is an
important definition so given the y is
the vector of moments in K dimensions
I've got K moments for this matrix so I
let F of Y be the forbidden set this
will be a subset of 0 pi it's an open
set it's the maximum open set such a for
any matrix a who's got those moments
it's got now eigen values there's an
exact statements but now I can values in
the set F of Y the bigger F of Y the
more I know so if K equals n I can
recover all the information so F of Y is
the complement of the eigen values ok
smaller what I want to understand
whatever wise the complement is where
the eigen values can lie on this level
set we call that the admissible set and
there is an enemy so like this is not a
problem where you can actually recover
information for every choice of a or
every choice of moment vectors my enemy
is a picket fence if the eigen values
are exactly in a progression and I take
the moments all the sums are basically
zero think of the unitary case all the
way up to so I learn nothing I can't
learn anything about any eigen value or
any interval if they are an arithmetic
progression and so algorithm is some
we're going to have to look for
variations from arithmetic progression
because that's my enemy
so this underdetermined problem cannot
be solved if you exactly on arithmetic
progression but you aren't on an
arithmetic progression because you are
in a random matrix situation and if you
were and now quickly explain this
philosophical point that I said that if
the eigen values really were coming down
randomly so if you chose a random
diagonal matrix rather than a random
matrix in so2 n plus 1 then these would
be a Poisson process and in a Poisson
process there are a lot of near
coincidences but there are big gaps and
the gaps are going to be my juice
they're very far from a para thematic
progression of porcelains process and
that's kind of critical
in this analysis so it's not a worry
it's just that any theorem that I state
will be for a typical a and that's what
happens in any application all right
besides this set there's another set
another set that is extremely important
to us it's a subset of the forbidden
said it's a set where I can compute the
exact number of eigen eigen values for
any a in the level set just given these
moments how many eigen values are there
in zero to y so are they miracle Y's in
which I can compute the exact number so
any computation when I'm finished is
exact its account that's an integer and
these are the two quantities I want to
compute F of Y the forbidden set and a
of Y the exact count set and the exact
can set is trivially contained in it
forbidden said that's easy to see and
the question is what can we do if alpha
is K over N and allowing alpha to go to
zero all right so obviously these are
moments of powers these are power sums
of powers of these eigenvalues so one
can re translate this to a question
about the moment curve and I'm going to
do that now originally we weren't
thinking in this language but later we
understood all our algorithms have a
beautiful interpretation in terms of
this so I want to explain that and now
I'm in the setting I think where
everybody should be quite happy I hope
me some tricks I'm really eager to see
some your ideas here
all right so change variable instead of
the eigen value being theta I make it
cosine theta
this makes the eigen values near the
biggest eigen value and smallest eigen
value squashed a little bit changes the
scale it's something that I'll return to
in a second when I show you some
pictures the moment curve is the
following you take the image of the
moment curve is this TT squared up to T
to the K in this notation I take the
image of minus one in R to the K so this
is a twisted curve like this that's the
moment curve and I'm now going to define
the key sets the a KN is the sum of C
plus seeds of this compact thing in
order to the K
end times so akka is the case where I
can recover all the all the coordinates
up to permit up to order by solving with
Newton's equations for the actual eigen
values but if n is bigger than K
remember I'm interested when K over N is
small okay and n are the same came in
then I'm taking this curve I'm adding it
to itself makovski some many times and I
get some weird set I'm going to show you
some pictures of it mistake and the
whole problem reduces to understanding
this set this under determined problem
so my basic problem to you guys is in
the Simon's Institute of complexity is
this in P or not the following problem I
give you a I give you K and n n is
bigger than K so the N is the number
that I give you I'm asking polynomial in
n can you tell me whether a given vector
is in the set or not you can do that I
can solve my problem very quickly in
polynomial time I can really run with us
so that's I don't have the answer to
this I would tend to think it isn't B
but I'm gonna show you our algorithms
sacrifices all algorithms do in and
we'll achieve something nevertheless but
not optimal I would be happy even if you
were able to just take a KK KK when n is
K I can compute when I'm in that or not
by just this Newton L by finding the
roots just take that set which I'm going
to show you a picture and add it to
itself once so this is N equals to K oh
and just tell me whether in that case I
can tell with them in this set which is
taking the spiky set convolving of
itself once very non convex set
convolving it with itself one meeting
adding it to itself once and then can
you tell if you in the set or not
okay I want you to answer it for random
guy will be good enough for random but
random a [ __ ] all not random okay
there will be an issue if you answered
this even for random uniform I'm also
interested it's a basic question yeah
correct but this question I think is a
very basic equation or even they said of
course I'm assuming real numbers and
computations can be done to infinite
precision yeah n times in K dimension
have already factored that in okay so K
equals n already takes their that into
account so K equals n is the K when N
equals K I can recover everything and
say if n is bigger than K maybe N is a
hundred times K then I don't know have
an algorithm you mean half of this and I
their curve has been took cows on and
have unfolded already so this is the
things not symmetric I'm gonna get to
the convex all that that's that's
obviously where you can it make some
progress correct but the real problem is
what you can do without going to the
convex hull because I'm going to show
you this much more information obviously
you're losing a lot of information all
right and why is this relevant suppose I
want to compute F of Y suppose I want to
see is T and I have this sum and I'm
saying is is T forbidden meaning there
is now some and which has T as an eigen
value and I just have to go through T
between minus 1 and 1
you discretize Rubinstein has this
running beautifully you discretize the
things are modulus of continuity and
things work very well so you discretize
don't worry about that you take Y minus
M of T and you ask is this in a KN minus
1 if you know how to do that in
polynomial time then you'll quickly get
the forbidden set instantly or in
polynomial time
test functions of your employee so the
reduction from the real problem to the
test function sets band-limited
functions cut-offs the a is eventually
the part of the matrix there is sort of
you can formulate it as an inverse major
problem with band-limited support but
then there's a way of reducing it to
this problem with a now following the
fact that the a from number theory will
follow with the haar measure on an
orthogonal matrix will be only because
of my conjectures with kids this
question so far no randomness my
question about whether this is in P
there's nothing to do with randomness so
in asking me this is in P now my
interest is only when it's random and
that'll help me this is what a three so
the moment curve if you add it to itself
five times in dimension two at the end
of trash on your picture in dimension
three it looks like this if you add this
further it'll just have many more of
these okay the color coding is exactly
related to this question that's the way
he did it was he generated points on the
moment curve with uniform measure and
then this is a density map so most
points land up in this part and the
central limit theorem says if you add
this and enough times this will become a
blob a round blob yeah this is uniform
in this picture
[Music]
on the curve Annika just uniform on the
curve which is a separate interesting
problem okay so you can see that these
spikes which you might want to exploit
which are the non convex parts disappear
when you start adding many times to
itself and in higher dimensions it's
complicated
alright this is the kind of thing that
you can see I just want to illustrate to
you so if you take maybe this is a good
example suppose you take K equals 30
so there are 30 eigenvalues here and
this is the so if I gave you all 30
moments I would get all the numbers back
this is giving myself 29 moments or
maybe this is a better picture if I have
five eigenvalues and in this case yeah K
will be five we in fact there n is five
K is five in there I recover everything
in these four K is 4 so the Forbidden
set is the complement here so this
eigenvalue you know essentially this
eigenvalue you know but does two
coalesced and this is an exact count set
so this is an exact count set the exact
count set and then you find that when of
course you have to now do something
serious in random matrix theory to see
what's going to happen for the random
guy here but if you have just a few less
moments then you do have this is the
real algebraic geometry in action
imagine I just have one less moment then
then the number of unknowns then you
have the you start off at a point which
you maybe generate which has all the
eigen values on a circle and the two
closest eigen values will move towards
each other if you move in either
direction and then bounce off so the
other eigen values don't even move and
you essentially know all the others and
that little interval is this interval
here which when n gets large is very
accurate so the real algebraic geometry
says that you'll be able to recover all
of the eigenvalues if you have K just a
little bit less than n but I'm
interested when K over N goes to 0
okay a little bit less than n it's not
so interesting in terms of what we're
trying to do alright so this is an
example of what those sets look like and
the only way are now to compute these
sets of size 30 is when you have the
number of moments is one less than the
total number of unknowns because then I
can run that algorithm by varying T and
I get to akk and akk are now dissolved
using Newton so if I have one less so
these are any food for J equals zero one
two meaning in this case they're 30
I can values and the number of moments
29 and 28 if I get down to 20 for this
algorithm wouldn't work and the only
algorithm are now is the one I'm about
to explain to you that's the thing oh
okay because it's it's a it's 70
pictures okay so we are efficient
algorithm of course convex so far is the
problem this is what we were doing
without realizing it before and even
though it convex if eyes a problem it
answers many questions which are way
beyond the convex hull but the first
thing you could say is let's ask whether
we in the convex hull but before I
explain that I'm going to generalize a
problem slightly because that's relevant
in our algorithm it's an iteration so
instead of having the moment curve plus
itself n times let me take a subset of
the moment curve because at each
iteration I will have learned something
new and I'll take the subset of the
moment curve so G is a subset of the
interval G of Y came from the previous
iteration I added to itself n times a
now get a much more complicated set
inside R to the K and I asked about
whether I can say determine with I mean
that's it well in this case if you allow
G to be quite general then you already
are np-complete so that's because you
can make the subset very complicated and
reduce down to the sub sum problem that
cough shot was np-complete so my hope is
that the first step is slow in P and the
first step
the most important I'll return to it but
for our iteration we need to run this
for general for more general G's and of
course we're not going to face this
np-complete problem we're going to
convex about the problem and that's of
course the main thing we relaxed the
problem and ask not whether the point is
in that set but in the convex hull and
then if you just rewrite what it means
to be in the convex hull at the first
step it becomes you'd write down a
separating hyperplane you get linear
program a beautiful linear program that
if you given the moments which oxy in
this case you want to find coefficients
B so that you minimize B and such that
the condition that for all T in your set
G I'm doing the second problem these are
inequalities and you want to minimize
this linear functional so that's just a
straight linear program that step one
this linear program has a beautiful
solution but on the iterative steps I
don't know how to solve it explicitly
anyway we run the linear program and
then there's a second linear program
which is for the exact count and that is
where we try count the number of
eigenvalues in an interval knowing only
these moments so we write try write an
upper bound and lower bound in terms of
linear functions so you have a set of
inequalities which again is a linear
program and then you minimize the upper
bound minus the lower bound so these are
I'll call it linear program one linear
program two will be part of an iterative
process which is very successful to get
these G's are going to be sub intervals
which you learn at each iteration
now the constraint on the on the bees is
linear for each T yeah but that's your
discrete that said it's not a problem
I'll get to this Hankel innocent but I
don't know how to get it to hang cool in
okay I'll get to that in a second okay
so this is a linear program it's just
got infinitely many constraints that's
correct
the sub-exponential runs with this but
with us iteration I think M is the
number of iterations K over 2 you're
already in the Congress all right
because every point of the conex all the
combination of roughly half of today
once I got to the convex so it's very
easy to describe the set yes if that's
what you're saying
4m eco K over to the moment or is it
selfs already complex no no no that sum
is never convex so every point in the
comment stop is accompanied now the
convex hull of of the of this set that I
call a and K is just the convert some of
the convex hull oh yes yes this yeah
that's correct yeah I'll be using that
at step one that's a that's a theorem oh
that's that's chebyshev's working it's
exactly ship ships it's called the
theory of ship ships weights and nodes
yep yeah if we go to the convex hull you
you then throw away that these are
points and you're really asking suppose
I have a measure and another measure
which has these moments to what extent
how much should I charge them an
interval and this problem for the entire
interval was solved ingeniously
brilliantly by chebyshev as and then
Markov gave it is complete proof anyway
you all know what the iteration is and
yeah so it's step one exactly it's step
one the question of whether you in the
convex hull has a so we I didn't know
this we found this something of course
these guys knew this long before us has
a semi definite description in terms of
making angle matrices which should be
positive semi definite so the question
whether in the convex hull of the set a
and K is very easy to answer in terms of
semi definite programming if it's the
whole interval but if it's a subset of
the interval they have tried and it's
extremely complicated because it gets
into very complicated problems about
orthogonal polynomials on Riemann
surfaces I don't see any very fast way
and we run a linear program in the
second iteration but for the theoretical
understanding of this we do this at this
stage and this has a very beautiful than
your program semi definite program but
this is what's relevant to what you
saying is the second problem of
optimizing the difference in the count
she'll be chef solved that in step one
ingeniously completely solved that
linear program explicitly using per day
approximations and using this theory of
nodes and weights which involve half the
number of variables that's exactly
correct and so both of these linear
programs which in general we run a
linear program or run at step one using
this much cleaner way of checking things
and when you do that the most important
step here is I should have explained
this step this is the most important
step here when in our problem if we have
an interval J where the upper bound and
the lower bound is less than 1 meaning
the upper count in the lower count which
is a integer lies between two numbers
which are less than 1 then I know how
many guys they are in there and that's
my exact count and that's the only
reason we so this is not part and parcel
of shabby ships work because they is
looking at arbitrary measures the
manager look at all three measures the
problem is immediately convex if I'd
because you're taking arbitrary measures
and moments so the problem is just the
convex hull problem and he solves it
completely for the interval but because
we are discrete bunch of points this is
the key new feature and allows us to
iterate
and do reasonably well in fact well
enough to be sub-exponential so notice
that allows me when I have an interval
which I'm trying to count the number of
exact number of points if the linear
program ends with this number less than
1 then I get this exact count and that's
what happens in practice we as I said
this is an example it's size 30 ignore
the top thousand more moments and you
need so this unfortunately he made it
for me yesterday we had other pictures
this is the forbidden this is a small
thing is a forbidden said not that's
tiny and we now we can get the whole
forbidden set at thirty by using the
full this is this convex of five this is
how much information we lost at 30 so at
30 we now everything this is all the
information for the book forbidden said
that we get however any piece of
forbidden sets gonna be good enough for
me to get some intervals and to compute
the route number that's the point and we
can go down to 20 yeah the forbidden
said this is at the edge where the
eigenvalues are squashed are these
intervals are bigger we can get all the
way down to 20 so 30 is not such a big
number the asymptotics that I'm going to
use in a minute only kick in slowly so
at 20 already I told you we could go
from 30 to 29 to 28 with a true problem
but look how much we losing so this is
why I'm really eager to see an improved
algorithm which is not purely based on
this convex a'f occation in iteration
because of the iteration we can answer
questions which are not purely convex
hull questions like the route number but
that's a separate question these are
more examples so let me emphasize here
that if it's step one they're forbidden
set is empty we stuck and this is where
the random comes in so if we're at step
one we happen to be the eigenvalues of a
matrix which are on a picket fence we
can't learn anything and we won't be
able to learn anything no matter what
algorithm we use the big thing that we
establish is that in the theory of
random matrix
depends heavily on the work of Gordon
and mater in the theory of random
matrices when these numbers get large we
will always have the forbidden set if
you choose the guide random be
non-trivial and quite big and so we
always have a non trivial forbidden set
and from that we'll be able to get the
exact count for special values and from
that we'll be able to also compute the
route number y the route if I can
compute the number of eigenvalues say
between minus 1 and t and y exactly then
i can tell whether there's an eigenvalue
at minus 1 rather than at 1 that's what
the difference is between the
determinant being plus 1 or minus 1 by
just the parity of the number of
eigenvalues so if I actually can break
this barrier and actually end the
forbidden set the minute the forbidden
sets non-empty the exact count set comes
with it and what we prove is that when
you have complexity going to 0 slowly we
have an optimize this then we always can
win and we always get the parity and we
always get the exact count and that's
sort of the main theorem by this
algorithm and it runs and it works very
well it has not been implemented on an
elliptic curve because when n is 30 then
the curve is got 10 to the 30 on dr. and
that's a that's a serious undertaking
but Rubinstein is doing that
I can't I don't know what happens is the
elliptic curve gives me the random guy
now there is something that I can do
here which is very important which is
why I always dreamt that out this will
lead to a much better than factoring and
that is I could take the elliptic curve
whose root number I'm trying to compute
and I can twist it with it there's some
operation I can twist it by a quadratic
character when you twist about quadratic
character just like I was telling you
the Legendre symbol the root number
changes in a way that you can compute
very quickly and then my other
conjectures of cats and mice myself say
then when you go over different
quadratic characters you sampling in
this relative to harm measure in this
orthogonal group that's been verified
and anyway this will be the running time
so you now can start sampling and you
just have to have one success of the
many many samples after which you will
have computed the root number without
ever factoring the number so you will
have computed the parity in this
interesting way so as I say we at the
level where we're competing with the
best factoring algorithms we trying to
beat that and that's where this issue
comes in at a practical level this other
P well if the thing is in P would
already improve things dramatically but
I always dreamt that we can go much
further I should say that if I have two
elliptic curves or two automatic forms
which have the same ApS for P up to log
squared then they actually are agree
forever
it's a theorem and the riemann and
because of that what we're trying to
compute it's not completely crazy all
the data is there in the small
coefficients issues can you extract the
information out of the data in an
efficiently quick way yep all right so
until recently my dream was still intact
but Johannsen and Lambert have blown
away any hope of fact of doing this in
polynomial time and let me explain it
absolutely stunning theorem which says
that there is no way that you will ever
do things that quickly have precisely
because random matrix Theory keeps the
eigen values rigid and
it's keeping this parity question a
secret so let me explain the theorem
suppose I am in O 2 n plus 1 and I don't
know where them got determinant 1 or
determinant minus 1 I don't know I look
at this moments in K dimensions N and K
o as before I look at the moments the
measure in R to the K if I were on the
determinant one component and the other
one is the determined minus one so both
of these are probability distributions
by variables in our to the K and all I'm
reading are these variables and I'm
trying from those variables to tell
whether on this component or that
component I mentioned to you arkansan
Polly so I have a very simple question
what's the total variation between these
two measures if that is not
exponentially small then I'm one I mean
I well if you tell me where these two
the probability distributions are
different and so the point is I keep on
reading this and I'm reading in the same
component all the time and at what point
do I have some statistic that'll tell me
I'm on this component rather their
component and tell me that route numbers
1 or minus 1 and I was always hoping
that that would go down to something
that's far better than factoring well
the theorem is and this is a very strong
Tiger limit theorem for K equals 1 John
Senden proved this and I suspect that
they will take it's big that his methods
won't work but he's sure they do these
two measures are so if K equals n to the
Alpha if K equals n over 100 we've
already now we can do everything that's
this alpha going to 0 but if I want to
start to compare you compete with
factoring I want this to be able to go
down like now we're competing exactly
with factoring its logs cube root of log
of the of the thing which is measured
here by this exponent so if K and the
1/3 is exactly the factoring so if K is
n to the one third he proves that the
total variation between these two is
exponentially small with an exponent
which is 2/3 so it shows that you'll
never do anything in Paulino
a polynomial number of steps these two
distributions are close to each other
you cannot distinguish and you can read
as much as you want you need to make an
exponential number of reads in order to
tell the difference between them so no
matter what I was doing there or how
clever you are with the moment curve
this sets a limit and the limit is only
set because this is random matrix Theory
if this were ordinary this would this
happens very quickly that you can
distinct we should do so this is kind of
disappointing that the conjecture of
cats myself actually it's exactly what
prevents you from reading this very
quickly but nevertheless our method is
apparently competing we haven't
understood it completely I think we will
have something which is in the same
ballpark as factoring never factors the
number computes a root number by this
algorithm and computes more than the
root number and it is I think all that
you can compute in some exponential time
so the main theorem is that you can do
this in sub-exponential town let me stop
I've gone over I'll give a picture now
this is a 3/4 from different angles to
where you come back to where you started
so when you face it from the one side
it's the a34 in dimension 2 and now he's
just moving around the density plot so
it's quite a complicated set even there
I'm asking
Oh give me an algorithm to determine
whether you in that set or not of course
it's a find it's the semi algebraic said
but I don't think you want to start
describing in large and what this
boundaries are you should be using
somehow the additive structure that it's
a man coughs key some
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah the to do this four random
permutations the observe larger
forbidden sex yes if you do it for
random diagonal matrices which I'll take
this so random so done permutation
matrices follow they follow random
matrix theory also it's slightly
different they have longest increasing
subsequence but that's all correspond to
Tracy wouldn't yeah I would imagine
that's the same but if you do random
diagonal completely different than this
works very quickly and you smile if if
the zeros of zeta function were random
person we would clean up big gaps so
they the intel girl rhythm is secretly
it finds these intervals where they you
wait for an interval which of as few
eigenvalues if there is such an interval
you find it quickly and then you use
that to get much more information than
iterate but if you don't find such an
interval so you need a unusual event
where the mean spacing is a little bit
larger by constantly and now you have a
paper with a number of other people here
which is the biggest eigenvalue that's
it they're much cruder level than what
we're doing here it's much much weaker
we're trying to because we're trying to
do an exact count so the answer I think
for permutation would be when I think it
would be the same as random matrices
because I'm sure things repel each other
so the moral of the story is I can
values of a random matrix are very rigid
in this event that you're looking for
which is a big gap it has to be waited
for a long time on the other hand if you
have a better way of using the so my
main question is is this thing in P and
find a better algorithm to search it's
non convex set you saw in the example I
gave you at 30 algorithm which convex
suffice gets a tiny little piece when in
fact we now you should be getting
everything that's how much information
the context if occation uses but it
doesn't lose that much information when
n goes large because we always get a
forbidden set
and then you actually need the forbidden
set the container large intro just oh no
the forbidden said the way we getting it
always isn't interval and the bigger the
interval the lower the complexity you
can deal with I mean it's kind of clear
intuitively because you can make a
function of low degree polynomial of low
degree which will approximate the
characteristic function by the way a
shabby chef's algorithms and with
Padilla approximations in the first step
to find that minimization problem is
just stunning it uses as he says it uses
half the number of variables in a clever
way and then the approximate gives you
two you instantly so the measure problem
is the convex problem is easy but this
is about the set
[Applause]